hello today we're going to talk about my
favorite President Teddy Roosevelt it's
in April night in April 18 okay in the
late 1890s President McKinley has
declared war on Spain Teddy Roosevelt is
the assistant secretary of the Navy the
Secretary of War at this a guy named
Alger Tay says Alger I want to go to war
I think this is what I need to feel like
a man and Alger laughed and he said okay
man if you really want this I'll make
you lieutenant colonel of the first US
volunteer cavalry regiment Teddy
Roosevelt says there is no one in the
world who's better suited to being a
cavalry officer than a cowboy he's got a
big old dick I spilled this all over my
shirt Teddy Roosevelt went to Texas
Oklahoma the Indian territories and New
Mexico Teddy Roosevelt says to a bunch
of cowboys guys what's up I need your
help
Spain sucks the US needs to go to war
with Spain let's do this the Cowboys say
yeah we're a hundred percent game we
know how to ride horses
the Indians say you guys are probably
gonna need trackers
we're cool like some of the Apaches
aren't cool with you guys but were cool
with you guys in addition to the cowboys
and Indians Teddy Roosevelt cause of his
old Ivy League buddies and he says guys
I'm going to war with Spain I know you
guys are not only super smart cuz you
got into Ivy League schools but you're
also super tough because you play sports
so why don't you join my regiment so
Teddy Roosevelt creates this army of a
thousand Ivy League athletes
cowboys and Indians the Rough Riders
[Music]
let's go right here okay whatever you're
comfortable okay are we good now Teddy
Roosevelt and his thousand Rough Riders
go to Cuba the transport ship isn't big
enough 300 guys have to stay behind
every other guy had to leave his horse
behind so these guys land in Cuba and
they get ambushed there in a valley
between two hills
where the Spanish have the upper hand
they're sitting ducks Teddy Roosevelt's
men start taking fire he loses over 200
of his men in this 20 minutes Teddy
Roosevelt rides up to the
second-in-command of the Regular Army
and he says we're getting our asses
kicked right now the only way we're
gonna survive is we charge up this hill
and the second-in-command of the Regular
Army says the colonel isn't here to make
that call I can't let you do that and
Teddy Roosevelt says I am a colonel it's
my call now
he rides unafraid of bullets to the
front lines here Teddy Roosevelt is here
his history and his people are standing
behind him he says I'm gonna go I'm
going up this hill and I'm gonna sleep
and I'm gonna defeat these Spanish
forces
follow me if you turn around I will
shoot you so Teddy Roosevelt led this
charge and all of the people followed
Teddy Roosevelt at the hip
they beat back the Spanish forces and
the Spanish forces retreated but Teddy
Roosevelt kept charging and within two
weeks Spain surrendered when he was
eleven years old
Teddy Roosevelt said if I'm gonna be
anything the thing that I'm gonna be is
a badass and that day he fulfilled that
promise to his young self and he became
a good rock star
mark mark uh-huh
I'm ready baby
[Music]